the ocean is a large mysterious scary
thing many horror stories and
supernatural sightings come from tales
of the deep such as sightings of a large
tentacle monster called the Kraken or
warnings of beautiful serenading
mermaids that pull sailors to the depths
to be eaten alive whether or not these
legends are real stories or just the
drunken recollections of fatigued
sailors their impact can be felt in the
hearts of every person who dares to sail
into unknown waters one of these brave
souls is none other than link from the
Wind Waker to no surprise the Zelda
universe has its own fair share of
supernatural legends and superstitions
but in the Wind Waker which mainly
features a large untamed ocean some of
these stories have come true at one
point in links adventure the courageous
hero is tasked with finding the pieces
of the Triforce of courage which have
been scattered throughout Hyrule after
the hero of time departed from the land
these pieces can be found by deciphering
charts that depict their locations
buried in chests at the bottom of the
sea but one of these triforce charts is
held in a chilling location legend has
it that on nights when the moon is
present an eerie green storm will take
the skies and a solemn haunting tune can
be heard wailing across the waves coming
from a ship with tattered sails sailing
without a single living soul aboard
those who are unfortunate enough to see
this curse at vessel refer to it as the
ghost ship truly one of the most
terrifying pieces of Zelda lore but a
ship with such importance to the hero's
journey and the will of the goddesses
must have some prior significance which
is hidden to us in present time so
without further ado follow me as we dive
deep into the mysteries underneath the
ghost ship
not much is revealed openly about this
ship in-game but what we are able to
find out is downright terrifying the
ghost ship will appear every night in a
different location across the Great Sea
depending on the lunar cycle of the moon
however to approach the ship without it
disappearing from sight once you get
near it
one must have in their possession the
ghost ship chart this is a mysterious
chart that seems to hold some magical
self-awareness
enabling it to indicate exactly what
step the moon is on in its cycle and
therefore where the ghost ship is
sailing upon that night
once link has obtained the ghost ship
chart the ship will no longer disappear
upon approaching it and can successfully
be boarded well if you call being warped
into its interior boarding according to
the eccentric adventurer photographer
man named Lenz Oh who has successfully
taken a picture of the ghost ship and
survived to tell the tale the chart was
made by an unknown man who quote
research to the reaches of the sea with
a ghost ship faded in and out of sight
and that he drew a map of his movements
but it is said that as soon as the man
had finished drawing the lines of that
cursed map he died a most unexpected
death whether it was the curse of the
ghost ship that doomed him to an early
grave or some other unfortunate means it
is heavily implied to be the former of
the two furthermore the chart is found
in a chest underneath of a diamond step
island in a hidden ship graveyard that
forms a complex maze once the chart is
obtained the next step is for link to
track it down and climb aboard when the
seas turn a sickly green and it begins
to storm you know the ship is nearby
there are a few important things to note
about its appearance firstly the ship
bears very strong resemblances to tetras
pirate ship in fact they're almost
exactly alike the colorations are
different though with tetris featuring
brighter red colors and the ghost ship
more of a faded mossy green palette both
ships feature artwork on the head of the
ship which do differ as well with Tetris
featuring the head of a serpent or
dragon and the ghost ships featuring
what appears to be an outward reaching
praying woman
the ship is also covered by what appears
to be flying blue flames which have been
indicated in other Zelda games such as
ocarina of time breath of the wild and
Twilight Princess to be what spirits
look like once inside the interior is
rather plain and resembles that of a
submarine from other portions of the
Great Sea but there are a few more
details in its interior that are rather
peculiar along the right wall there's a
beam of light that is seeping in through
a crack somewhere and where it shines a
lone white flower is blooming the floor
is lined with a ghastly mist and the
ceiling is cracked open permitting you
to see ghostly spirits surrounding the
chamber you're in indicating this is
some different plane of existence from
where you are physically in the Great
Sea hanging just above the treasure
chest which is accessible after
defeating the monsters within the ship a
strange portrait of a face is present
this face emits a demonic terrifying
grin that disappears into an
expressionless face when link walks
closer and finally the chest holds a
Triforce chart which reveals the
location of one of the eight shards of
the Triforce of courage in the HD remake
it has been replaced with just
straight-up a shard of the Triforce of
courage after link picks up the treasure
a sudden painful sounding yell is heard
and Link's consciousness fades to black
when he wakes up he's aboard the king of
Red Lions and the ghost ship is never to
be seen or heard of again okay now that
we're all in the same page with the ship
let's start piecing together what all
this madness could mean the entire
purpose of the vessel is to guard one of
the shards of the Triforce of courage as
indicated by what's in its treasure
chest and the fact that it no longer
haunts the Seas once link obtains said
treasure the Triforce as mentioned
before was shattered into eight pieces
once the hero of time left Hyrule it's
believed that the Triforce was shattered
to hide it away this seems to indicate
that the ship and its crew were
commissioned by the goddesses to guard
the shard of the Triforce from those who
would seek it for evil such as Ganon
it's possible that the ship is actually
an evil entity who is keeping the shard
from link in order to serve Ganon but
that doesn't make too much sense since
ganador actually wants all pieces of the
Triforce for himself and if it were a
haunted vessel by his doing he would
simply take the shard for himself by
this point but what the goddesses really
command a vessel
be haunted for all eternity and even
release monsters incited to guard the
Triforce yard well to be honest this is
the same game that revealed the
goddesses in their benevolence to have
literally flooded the entire world and
efforts to kill Ganondorf meaning they
are no strangers to taking drastic
sometimes tragic measures for the
greater good
so drafting a ship into eternal service
seems pretty plausible as well we also
see from other Zelda titles that's
serving the goddesses after death is
rather common especially among the
sheikah clan but even if the ghost ship
was made by the goddesses for righteous
purposes who were the poor souls made to
service the goddesses for all eternity
and why did the man charting the ship's
locations died unexpectedly and whose
spirits are these that we can see
floating around the vessel well as far
as those floating spirits go they are
actually the spirits of dead seagulls
that have been tied to the ship seagulls
are shown in game to fly around Tetris
ship and even the tiny king of Red Lions
and these unfortunate birds were bound
for all eternity to haunt the Seas
alongside the ghost ship but the ship
was once manned by a crew that much is
certain although I believe the answer to
who those individuals were may not be
what you're expecting let's recap our
Clues so far the ghost ship resembles
Tetris ship very closely in both build
and design as well as every other ship
in the graveyard we see underneath
diamond step Island these ruined ships
are further tied to the ghost ship due
to the fact that they house the ghost
ship chart these and Tetris ship are the
only vessels in the entire game that
resemble one another and they do so with
almost suspicious accuracy Tetris ship
has been in her family bloodline for at
least two generations since we know that
before her leadership it was her mother
who was captain tetra is later revealed
to be zelda spoiler warning I guess and
we can see a portrait of the hero of
time in her chambers inside the ship who
was only depicted one other time in the
submerged hyrule castle leading to the
next logical question of why and how she
would have this picture at all
considering her royal history and this
strangely added image of the ancient
hero of time could it be that tetra ship
is actually from old Hyrule would've
all those ships resembling Tetris pirate
ship are actually from the old Hylian
fleet that rose to the surface under the
goddesses protection when Hyrule was
flooded long ago and that is when the
Princess Zelda of that time be it tetras
mother or grandmother or whoever in
order to save her own bloodline became a
pirate alongside the ancestors of her
current pirate crew relating this back
to the ghost ship it could be just one
of the other ships in the fleet that had
then been given the task of rowing the
Seas for all eternity protecting the
shard of the Triforce with the souls of
the entire remaining haile and sailors
bound to the vessel explaining the
rather large number of ghostly
apparitions that can be seen along the
floors and ceiling inside the ship the
goddesses then took the remaining ships
from the fleet and hid them away in a
large ship's graveyard maze hiding the
ghost ship chart as far as why the man
from lenses legend who drew the chart
died unexpectedly for all we know this
could just be a frightening legend since
it's unlikely a mere mortal man could
create the chart with its magical
properties in the first place
with the ships origins crew and curse
explained I think that wraps up this
mystery pretty well but what do you
think does the ghost ship have another
origin let me know in the comments below
thank you all so much for watching as
always it's been a blast working on this
theory and it was of course exciting to
get to share it with you be sure to LIKE
this video if you liked it and subscribe
if you haven't already for much more
Zelda and Nintendo content to come huge
thank you to my amazing patrons of which
I have two new additions welcome to
Thomas McClure and Amanda mull so you
guys are amazing and I'm so honored to
have you in my videos if you're
interested in getting your name up here
at the end of all my videos follow the
link in the description below to find
out how also down there are links to my
Twitter and discord and you know other
places to get in touch with me directly
so be sure to check that out too that's
all I've got for you today so as always
I hope you have a phenomenal rest of
this is massimino bandit signing out
[Music]